le grand patron de la sqdc Jacques
farcite avec nous se faire si bonsoir
bonsoir Monsieur bon alors quatre ans
plus tard est-ce que pour simplifier
vous est-ce que c'est un succès dans
votre à votre avis la légalisation je
crois qu'après 4 ans le modèle québécois
a fait ses preuves nous avons capté 58%
du marché vers la sqdc vers le sol canal
légal au Québec on a également une
mission qui est très importante pour
nous et pour le Québec une mission de
protection de la santé donc on vend du
cannabis dans une perspective de
protection de la santé et on a fait tout
ça dans un cadre économique qui fait du
sens pour le Québec puisqu'on est
capable de livrer des profits à la
société québécoise on va prendre ça une
chose à la fois justement mais on
commence avec la conso parce que la
question la crainte se farcis au départ
c'était que les gens consomment
davantage les jeunes notamment or il y a
eu une augmentation quand on prend les
15 ans et plus là c'est tout le monde
jusqu'à 90 ans 14% en 2018 disait
consommer la mariju
2021 19%. il y a eu une augmentation des
consommateurs pas une bonne nouvelle
alors comme vous le dites c'est une
étude qui part sur la base du déclaratif
et peut-être que en 2018 juste avant ou
juste après la légalisation les
consommateurs étaient peut-être un peu
moins décomplexés à parler de leur
consommation donc aujourd'hui peut-être
il y a une progression mais en tout cas
si elle existe elle est sans doute très
mesurée bon vous avez dit on est réussi
à aller chercher du marché noir une
partie importante du marché on a le
chiffre également vous dites enfin on
dit que vous avez 58% du marché le
marché noir conserve 42%. moi ça me
semble assez optimiste pour vous vous
êtes vraiment vous avez vraiment réussi
à aller chercher 60% du marché alors le
chiffre qui est absolument certain c'est
le tonnage que la sqdc vend chaque année
donc l'année dernière on a vendu près de
110 tonnes de cannabis donc ça ce
chiffre là il n'est pas contestable ou
c'est vraiment le suivi très réguliers
de nos ventes bien sûr pour être capable
de savoir le pourcentage il faut le
ramener un total du marché ça c'est un
c'est une estimation qui nous est donnée
par le ministère des Finances cette
estimation pour l'année dernière était
de 187 tonnes donc quand on fait le
rapport des 110 tonnes que nous avons
vendu sur l'estimation la taille estimée
du marché c'est là où nous avons les 58
%. sainte-titres quand même énorme
quelqu'un disait dans le petit vidéo
juste avant ça dépend du prix le
la mafia en fait les gens qui vendent au
marché noir se sont adaptés 20 moins
cher sont agressés vous le voyez vous le
constatez alors sur les prix en fait il
y a des situations assez différentes il
y a un segment de marché qui s'appelle
le 28 grammes Lons qui représente les
achats en très gros volume sur ce
segment là on le sait le marché noir
pratiquant des rabais plus vous achetez
en volume les prix sont très sont très
dynamiques et la sqdc ne compétitionne
pas sur les prix du marché noir sur ce
format là en revanche sur le format qui
est le format standard du marché de 3 on
a des produits qui sont tout à fait
comparables exactement au même prix que
les prix du marché noir mais évidemment
la sqdc amène des produits de qualité
des produits contrôlés pour certains au
même prix que le marché noir et pour
d'autres plus valorisés est-ce que c'est
pas ça la grande avancée parce que qui
est plus de consommateurs je pense qu'on
peut le voir
ça dépend des études remarquées pour
être exactes faut dire que chez les
jeunes l'étude montre que ça a baissé la
consommation donc vous devriez être
heureux de ça j'imagine tout à fait tout
à fait je crois que ça va dans le bon
sens bon mais c'est sur la qualité du
produit on sait ce qu'on achète chez
vous en fait c'est ça votre ventre
exactement le principal bénéfice d'aller
dans un marché dans le seul marché légal
au Québec là sqdc je le rappelle c'est
vraiment la seule destination légale au
Québec c'est d'aller à la sqdc les
normes bénéfice c'est que vous savez
exactement le type de produit que vous
êtes en train d'acheter la teneur de ce
produit en THC qui est un des
cannabinoïdes qui donne l'effet
psychotrope donc effectivement nos
produits sont parfaitement contrôlés et
vous êtes certain de la qualité de ce
que vous êtes en train d'acheter et vous
n'encouragez pas les jeunes à commencer
à consommer non on encourage ni les
jeunes ni les moins jeunes à consommer
on est dans une logique de donner accès
aux produits aux produits contrôlés mais
évidemment on n'est pas dans une logique
tel qu'un commerce en traditionnel peut
le faire de stimuler le marché notre
mission est parfaitement claire sur le
fait que nous devons amener des
consommateurs du marché illégal vers la
solution légale la sqdc mais sans
stimuler la demande c'est à dire sans
demander ou sans proposer de consommer
plus le gouvernement fait quand même de
l'argent avec vous on va voir le
troisième et dernier tableau vous avez
envoyé 70 millions en 2020 2021 et bien
c'est le début
66,5 mais vous me disiez c'est plus
élevé même exactement la dernière année
on est passé à 75 millions je dirais sur
les profits directs de la sqdc pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 600 millions de
ventes mais au-delà de la contribution
directe par les profits également toutes
les taxes qui sont versées au
gouvernement et c'est plus 210 millions
qui sont versés au gouvernement
québécois le modèle québécois je vous
disais est un modèle qui a fait ses
preuves parce que le législateur a
décidé dès le démarrage que cet argent
avait un usage particulier ça n'est pas
versé dans le budget général du Québec
c'est vers vraiment versé avec un
objectif particulier qui est la
recherche sur le cannabis et également
la lutte contre les dépendances et le
les besoins de recherche autour du
cannabis on réinvestit l'argent tout à
fait pour lutter contre les dépendances
est-ce que vous voulez
rendre ça encore plus accessible je sais
que vous ne faites pas la livraison si
si alors oui oui on fait on fait on fait
la livraison on fait la livraison donc
vous avez trois types de livraisons vous
avez la livraison standard donc le
lendemain par pose Canada on a également
une livraison le soir même dans les
grands centres donc la grande région de
Montréal la grande région de Québec je
suis dépassé et la livraison 90 minutes
que nous sommes en train de 90 minutes
que nous sommes en train de tester sur
la ville de Québec et la zone du
Saguenay la Saint Jean et pas à Montréal
non pas encore à Montréal on est en fait
sur le 88 minutes on est sur une logique
de test pour comprendre comment ce
système peut trouver son public et peut
répondre à un besoin des consommateurs
mais c'est des coursiers quoi c'est que
vous engagerez en fait c'est une société
une coopérative québécoise qui s'appelle
Eva qui travaille pour la sqdc et qui
s'assure de faire la livraison dans les
conditions de sécurité c'est-à-dire que
évidemment on va vous demander votre
preuve d'identité au moment de vous
remettre votre colis au chauffeur de pas
fumer ou d'avaler des substances avant
tout à fait ça on s'assure que tout est
bien fait monsieur farci quand on est
PDG SQD c'est ce qu'on doit goûter les
produits vous en fumez vous en avalez
vous en cuisinez non alors non je ne
suis pas consommateur de produits
cannabis non non je n'étais pas avant je
ne le suis pas devenu j'ai pas curiosité
vous êtes là alors je suis très curieux
sur le cannabis je me documente
énormément mais pas au point d'aller
consommer la meilleure consommation
c'est souvent ce qu'on y a de nos à nos
clients c'est de ne pas en consommer
donc je n'en ai profité ça cuit avant
tout à fait vous buviez du vin j'imagine
alors je déguster du vin effectivement
je trouve que à la SAQ quand on déguste
on peut cracher pour le cannabis c'est
un peu plus c'est particulier donc je ne
suis pas consommateur pour le moment bon
bon on rit là mais il y a des vraies
questions qui se font pour ne pas
encourager les jeunes à consommer vous
vous avez décidé à faire le gouvernement
des sites au Québec de ne pas faire des
gélules ou des bonbons rien qui
ressemble à des bonbons ça ça bougera
pas alors c'est dans la loi donc la loi
est très claire sur le fait de dire les
comestibles solides ça ne peut pas être
ni des jujubes ni du chocolat ni des
produits attractifs pour les jeunes donc
on trouve des produits comestibles
infuser au cannabis mais qui ne sont pas
attractifs pour les jeunes on en propose
depuis le 5 avril plusieurs versions et
c'est des versions qui sont un peu
surprenantes au démarrage mais qui
trouve leur public aujourd'hui
monsieur farci merci beaucoup puis
peut-être que vous allez essayer vous
allez adopter non aussi des questions de
santé qui fait que vous n'avez pas envie
j'en éprouve pas le besoin
c'est une bonne raison merci beaucoup
monsieur le parti d'être venu nous voir
studio merci bonne soirée au revoir